die comex geschäfte ein komplexes
verwirrspiel mit aktien
dabei wurden mehrere milliarden euro an
steuergeldern erschlichen
doch der reihe nach einmal im jahr
werden aktionäre direkt am gewinn eines
unternehmens beteiligt mit der dividende
25 prozent davon fließen direkt als
steuer an den staat eigentlich simpel
dividenden für fonds oder banken sind
aber von der steuer ausgenommen
sie erhalten eine steuerbescheinigung
und können sich diese dann
zurückerstatten lassen
ziel der comic stil der
steuerbescheinigungen erhalten als
eigentlich steuern gezahlt wurden
dafür braucht es mindestens drei
beteiligte eine gute absprache und den
richtigen zeitpunkt die aktien werden
trickreich vor der gewinnausschüttung
und danach zwischen den dreien hin und
her geschoben
die behörden sollen nicht mehr
nachvollziehen können wer wann welche
aktie erhalten hat mit oder ohne
dividende und vor allem wer alles
bescheinigung bekommen hat und wer
wirklich steuern gezahlt hat die folge
das finanzamt verliert den überblick und
so werden steuern am ende nicht nur
einmal erstattet sondern gleich mehrfach
mindestens 31 milliarden euro wurden
somit comic stil und seinen
verschiedenen varianten allein in
deutschland erschlichen
aber auch behörden in dänemark belgien
frankreich der schweiz und italien
erstatteten steuern die nie gezahlt
wurden
juristisch soll jetzt geklärt werden
haben anleger und banken lücken im
gesetz genutzt oder gezielt
steuerhinterziehung betrieben
bekannt sind diese praktiken zumindest
offiziell bereits seit 2001 aber erst
elf jahre später wurde ein gesetz
verabschiedet dass diese comics
geschäfte unterbinden sollte
bundesregierung und experten sind sich
bis heute nicht einig dies wirklich
gelungen ist